Rejoice with me, brethren, for behold
All right, I had to throw that out
seeing how close we are to Halloween.
But yes, my latest book, The Two Swords
of Christ, is finally born.
I just received my author copies, the
very first in existence, and wanted to
share my joy with you.
I'm sure many authors agree, but seeing
all your hard work finally manifest in
the flesh, as it were, is a very
pleasing experience.
Now, it's a hefty volume, 512 pages, my
longest yet, with four maps, uh 16 pages
of full-color
pictures. I don't know if you can see,
but uh yeah, you will see. Now, for a
more detailed overview of what the book
is about, check out an earlier video I
did, link in the description. But in
brief, it's a comprehensive history of
the Christian military orders,
especially the two most important, the
Templars and the Hospitallers.
It's about their origins, their
rationale, their theology, one of the
most interesting aspects, and of course,
their long conflict with Islam.
Incidentally, of all my books, uh this
is the one that most directly covers the
Crusades. Although it's not about the
Crusades per se, the orders were so
central to them, often their backbone,
that it was inevitable to explore those
holy wars in detail. So, for all you
Crusade fans, uh this is the book for
you. But it also goes far beyond the
Crusades, which traditionally end around
1291 in the Holy Land.
The book's subtitle is Five Centuries of
War between Islam and the warrior monks
of Christendom, because it roughly
covers the years between 1100 and 1600.
Though I really go all the way to the
present, discussing how these orders are
remembered and understood today. Now,
many of you have asked how to get an
advance copy. The official release date
is November 25th, about a month from
now.
If you pre-order on Amazon, where it's
currently the number one best-selling
new release in the history of
Christianity category, I'm happy to say,
you'll receive it on or after that date,
November 25th. However, I've decided to
part with 10 or so of my author copies.
If you'd like one, uh visit my website,
link in the description, make a
much-appreciated donation, and I'll
sign, personalize, and mail you one of
these newly-minted copies.
Depending on how soon you order, say you
order today, you'll get it almost a full
month before everyone else. Now, let me
close by reading a short excerpt to give
you a taste of the book's contents and
tone. This comes from chapter 46, and
it's about one of the masters of the
Knights of St. John, the Hospitallers,
whose name was John of Heredia.
He became a knight in 1328 at age 17 in
Aragon, Spain.
After half a century of warfare against
the Moors of Spain, he was elected
master of the Order of the Knights of
St. John in 1377 at the age of 67.
Now, here's a brief excerpt of what
happened next.
Quote, "After setting sail from Naples
to assume his new position as master of
the Knights of St. John in Rhodes, he
and his men encountered a Venetian fleet
off the coast of Morea battling the
Turks, who had just seized the town of
Patras from Venice.
Coming aboard the master's vessel, the
Venetian general begged him, for the
common good of Christendom, to join
forces with him to recover Patras out of
the hands of the infidels." These are
quotes.
Although the newly-minted master's
presence was urgently needed in Rhodes,
his courage prevailed over his interest,
and he embraced with joy an occasion of
signalizing his warlike talents against
the eternal enemies of his order.
So, the two fleets joined, landed their
troops, and marched straight to Patras.
The siege was long and hard, and, quote,
now this is a quote from a primary
source,
"The order lost several knights of
distinction, but at last, the machines
made use of in those times, having made
a breach, the master, impatient of so
long a resistance, takes a ladder, claps
it to the breach, mounts up first sword
in hand, and without minding whether he
was followed or not, throws himself into
the place.
The Turkish governor, on his side,
opposes his progress with great courage.
A duel ensues between them till the
Christian, more expert or else stronger
than the infidel, runs him through,
kills him, cuts off his head.
While his knights, uncertain of the
master's fate, mount up the breach in
crowds to his succor, bear down all
before them, and breaking into the
place, put the garrison to the sword."
End quote. And this is me now continuing
in the book. Not content, and apparently
now taken by a war frenzy, the
67-year-old master and veteran of many
battles against the Moors of Spain,
continued alongside the Venetians deep
into Morea until he was captured by the
Turks. On learning of his identity, they
sent him to a castle in Corinth and kept
him under strict guard. His men
compelled the Venetians to offer to
return Patras to the Turks in exchange
for their master's release.
But the Muslims haughtily refused,
saying that, quote, "Being masters of
the Morea, they knew how to recover that
place in less time than the Christians
had employed in reducing it." His
inconsolable knights would not relent
and offered, beside Patras, a very
considerable sum of money and three
grand priors as hostages to be kept
until the whole was paid. The Turks
agreed, but when they informed the
master of the good news of his upcoming
release, he refused to consent that
three grand priors should become
hostages on his account.
Preferring riches and Patras to some old
infidel, the Turks allowed his knights
to visit and implore John Heredia to
reason, but in vain did his knights
labor by their prayers and tears to gain
his consent for this exchange. Nothing
could shake his resolution. He would not
even allow the order to pay his ransom.
"If it must be paid," said he, "my
family has received estate enough for me
to give this proof of their gratitude."
In other words, if someone's going to
pay for it, it should be his own family.
"Otherwise, uh let me alone, my dear
brethren," he continues, "suffer a
useless old man that cannot live much
longer to die in prison, and do you, who
are younger, reserve yourselves to be
serviceable to the order."
Not knowing what to do, the confused
Turks sent him away into captivity. He
was shut up in a close prison, and
instead of enjoying his new dignity as
master of Rhodes, he was kept above
three years in a rigorous slavery. His
family eventually managed to ransom him.
Rather than retiring with every possible
honor, Heredia, now 70, picked up right
where he left off. He sailed to Rhodes,
resumed his mastership, and led his
knights into many more victorious
battles against the Muslims until 1396,
when the 86-year-old battle-scarred
master did at last succumb to mortality.
And that's just one of many such men
you'll encounter in these pages.
All right, there it is. I hope you'll
consider pre-ordering The Two Swords of
Christ from your preferred bookseller so
you can receive it around November 25th.
Or, if you want an early signed copy,
follow the link in the description. Bye
for now.